greetings from podcast Ville the Church
of what's happened now is brought to you
by Squarespace listen turn your cool
idea into a new website sell products
and services of all kinds and announce
an upcoming event or special project and
more right now you go to twist based
calm and I'm gonna give you a free trial
when you you're ready to launch you use
offer code Church to save 10% off your
first web site or domain you understand
me Squarespace is the way to go if you
want it because they have beautiful
templates created by world-class
designers powerful ecommerce
functionality lets you sell anything
online and the ability to customize look
and feel settings products and more with
just a few clicks when you're ready to
put that website together or get your
domain squarespace.com is the way to go
so go to Squarespace calm right now for
a free trial when you ready Iraq use
offer code Church CH you are CH to save
10% off your first purchase of web site
or a domain that squarespace.com at the
code church I love to introduce this
company to the podcast into the church
family and at CBD listen picking a
reliable CBD company is like pulling
[ __ ] teeth that [ __ ] ends to that you
know why because Uncle Joe is gonna hook
you up with CBD Lyon listen they make
CBD products from start to finish
CBD Lyon has you covered alright if you
love to vape they got caught cartridges
and the shadow but if you're not into
smoke and let me tell you something they
got these [ __ ] gummies that's how I
was introduced to it and the Tang [ __ ]
you put the tension under your tongue
30 seconds you swallow tip-top
[ __ ] Magoo I'm 56 years old I
go to to jujitsu is a week to kick
boxing is a week and a strength lifting
class a week and you know what's been
helping me the most lately CBD lines
what i'm gonna do is this go to CBD lyon
calm and check out the third party lab
results yourself but right now the
church family gets 20% off anything
Gummy's [ __ ] teaches [ __ ] shack
you got we got for you if you need CBD
this is the company let me explain
something to you when I read their flyer
I was so impressed they even tell you
how CBD works with your body so don't be
afraid right now cut the [ __ ] go to CBD
line calm if you want to rub it on your
shoulder if you want to rub it on your
knee whatever CBD you need CBD Lyon has
your cupboard so go to CBD line right
now and get 20% off your order
when you put in church at checkout all
right that's CBD line calmly kick this
[ __ ] meal it's my little
brother Redman what's happening what's
up buddy
ah it's just one of those weeks I
figured we need a [ __ ] chat with red
band and I get back to the [ __ ] oh
jeez of [ __ ] podcasting how are you
doing okay you know it's been a rough
couple weeks but it's uh I'm doing
firing what the [ __ ] did you eat in
England that gave you choices I want to
know this [ __ ] right now III think it's
I think it was the oysters and I really
don't get a stirs in Ireland I don't
think I'm going to get oh I love oysters
ooh and I don't like Rogan got me on cuz
he would always get a wasters I was
always scared of them but then I grew to
love them and and I loved like all the
things that you get from oysters island
like an island or on the water
yeah it should be fine but but I think
the place we we got the oysters that was
like a tourist trap it's like getting
Easter's at Hollywood Hollywood in
Highland you know II had some kind of
pub you know like you know you don't go
there to get oysters but uh yeah it was
bad that was the worst food poisoning
ever and we all got it so a little bit
last 24 hours me Tony Hinchcliffe
Jeremiah Watkins Joel will jiménez that
are the Mexican drummer that we have in
kill Tony didn't get it because he's
Mexican we think in and yet as Strummer
it's the stronger stomach is the lizard
me oh damn yeah [ __ ] eyeballs you and
I got cramps but uh it we then in the
morning after we ate or we had to go to
Manchester
we had to go to the airport like 7:00
a.m. or whatever it was and we all go to
the lobby and I look at Tony and I look
at Jeremiah I'm like dude I've been
puking all night both ends [ __ ]
puking he's like I can't even believe
that I packed my suitcases to get out
and Tony looks at me goes I just went
from the bathroom at the same [ __ ]
Jeremiah is like I feel really really
bad and then we get into the cab and
we're driving to the airport and then
Toni Sykes stop stop stop
we're in the middle of this traffic jam
highway and Tony runs out pukes and then
and then like five minutes later I'm
opening the door Mike stop and I'm and
I'm like puking out the side of it we're
at the airport puking and [ __ ] all
three of us going crazy I mean it was I
think I should have been in the hospital
like that bad of food poisoning like
uncontrollable like one second you're
just puking and [ __ ] you can't
control him you said you were little
rough to a cop at the yep yeah yeah I
was after I finally checked my bag in
and whatever I was like we had to get to
the gate and we haven't gone through
like them like the the security or
anything like I'm like this is gonna be
the I'm gonna die in at this airport I
see a cop and I'm just sweat and I'm
about to pass out like I thought I was
gonna faint I see a cop and I'm like
about to though hey you know help me
take me to the hospital but I couldn't I
didn't have enough energy and I was too
scared I just kept on walking and man
that Airport situation was like an hour
of just like I thought I thought that
was that's where I was I played with
well Tony gave me a bag like a ziploc
bag and he goes here you know just in
case and I'm like all right I put in my
pocket and we in my opinion I don't
think I think all of us should have went
to the hospital but we were just so like
you know we have a show tonight
in Manchester we have to get on this
plane and so I'm on the plane I'm just
like trying not to you can do anything
suddenly in the middle flight I pull out
that ziplock bag I fill it to the rim
and and luckily I had eight I was trying
to drink Gatorades and types type stuff
just so I had electrolytes and stuff so
when I puked it just smelled like
strawberries so I don't think anyone was
like oh he's puking it was more like
what's going on over here cuz I was like
cowered in the corner like puking and
then I just zipped it up put it
my in my coat because I didn't want
anyone to know it luckily was only an
hour flight or something like that like
going to Vegas and when we landed I had
this bag of puke and I had to like go
how it and like find a trash can there
was no trash cans anywhere so I had to
hide my little bag of puke it day at the
airport and like underneath these carts
but then we had a show that night all of
us like were dead like we were sleeping
two minutes before we're supposed to be
on the stage of this theater we're all
in the back laying on the floor of this
dirty floor in this green room and we
did the show and we're all just about to
die and halfway through the show Tony
finally goes hey just so you know we're
all about to die right now like like we
just got over food poisoning luckily
twelve hours later we were in London and
everything was fine but man having food
poisoning a it while traveling be in a
different country see it was one of the
worst that is my biggest fear it's was
the worst biggest fear is getting sick
on the road mmm I had a you know I got
problem sleeping but because the sleep
apnea machine I can't do the heavy duty
sedation pills nothing so I went
somewhere it was when we were doing the
podcast at 6:00 in the morning
my sleeping was all over the place we
were getting up at five two days a week
and Thursday I would fly out at five and
then Friday you have radio so it was
like give you your sleep patterns just
[ __ ] and I remembered is Amy's in
Chicago and you have to do downtown
Thursday and then Friday and Saturday
you go to the club on the outside of the
Chicago close to O'Hara have Rosemont
Rosemont and that Friday I was fine and
that night at the 7-eleven when I went
to get rolling papers I bought time or
PMS and I popped whatever it says one or
two when I [ __ ] went to bed and I got
up in the middle of night and I had swam
at the hotel of the day before what made
me swim with no heat plugs on
so the here the water got stuck in my
[ __ ] right here and I'll never forget
getting up and just falling straight
down and go and thank God there wasn't
the table or a desk thank God I fell and
like I think I was ever on my suitcase
broke the fall and I could had vertigo
Wow and that like the two scariest times
I had a DC one time I was doing that
testosterone all those guys Joe and
those guys like you're getting older do
the testosterone I was doing a
testosterone sucking I got a plane had a
headache but it wasn't just a regular
headache it wasn't my neck my god damn
this is one of those real antics I got
the DC I took blood pressure medication
and still I had that headache and I
[ __ ] did the show went this what
happened that Monday I went for a blood
test and I had DC that weekend and that
Friday I woke up with a headache and
with dr. Cole at had a little message
like oh why the [ __ ] is he calling me
and I call him back my home what
somebody goes where are you I'm in DC he
goes go to a hospital they're gonna take
blood out here I need for them to take
as much blood I love you as they can
because you develop them more red blood
cells than white one the testosterone
backfired on me something happened so I
had to go to the [ __ ] hospital no
money I fainted like six times yeah I
remember that at all I got back to my
hotel room I got a cab back I drank a
can of coke couple cans of coke when I
got back to the hotel about 6:15 the
first show was at 8:00 there's the first
time I'm gonna have to cancel and I go
hold on one second when we got a can of
coke if the coke don't do it nothing
will and that was the first time I had
drank Coke and like three years it was
horrible it was too [ __ ] sweet I
drank the whole can of coke I was backed
at all I did the show there's a
commercial for coke right there guys
yeah
having a blood test when they give you
they give you a Coke and like a Gatorade
or cookie I think it's my I had I was so
poor that I would get plasma once or
twice a week or something like that and
I I like you hate needles I don't have
any veins so they're always trying to
have to like poke it a million times to
find a vein but I would give plasma and
they would give us a check for like $45
or 80 bucks or something like that and
they would give it so I could buy
marijuana and have some money for beers
that night never did that once or twice
a week may Oh miss those days how long
would it take like an hour I think
because they when you get plasma what it
does is it takes out your blood you
would hate this the most it takes out
your blood and it takes the plasma from
the blood and it's like this machines
behind you that's just spinning out your
blood and then it puts the blood back in
so it's like it it's it takes the plasma
of your blood but you get your blood
back type [ __ ] it's it was not worth it
and that's how broke I was though like I
was doing [ __ ] like that when I was in
college well I don't know whether that's
gonna take over weight today if you look
at yellow color vision
I want a shot when I'm in use shaving
cream I just use like [ __ ] fungus
soap that's what I didn't want to use
this shaving cream tonight so use like
[ __ ] that that body whatever one you
go to jiu-jitsu yeah yeah I use that and
I shaved I come out of the [ __ ]
shower just today one o'clock and I
[ __ ] went the white my face was
bleeding and I was in front of the
mirror and I had actually sit out and I
said oh yeah just the slide on it just a
little bit of blood just said I'll just
to get and I knew I what I don't even
trust it because I never know when it's
gonna hit what about the time like I'm
the Southwest and there was turbulence
and I was in the bathroom and I actually
there was turbulence and I was pissing
but the plane made me go forward so I
banged my head on the thing no but I
nodded all guys it wasn't a big deal at
all but as I was washing my hands I go
what if the plane does it now and I bang
my head in that mirror I'm gonna start
bleeding
oh I fainted just before
like I barely made it back to the
[ __ ] Southwest flight seat in the
middle like I had a hold on just the
idea that that was a time I was with
Gabriel and those guys and I'd take my
shirt off and my big tits were hanging
and I'm sweating on the plane and it was
when Southwest has facing seats I think
I took an edible - that was when those
are Dunkin four things I mean yeah
Listerine strips or like 100 milligram I
never tried those they were stuck
together oh you'd put them in your
wallet right and then we get stuck
together so you didn't know what are you
eating two of them or 18 of them mm-hmm
and I put one in one morning on a flight
and it just took off and that's what God
had ignited was me thinking about
hitting the glass not even hitting it
there was no blood involved just the
thought guys like I said tell your blood
on Monday and it's been eating away at
me Sunday I'll be a mess Sunday I'll be
a mess that's what I'm going to see
Whitney on Sunday she's running in our
hour how come for the Netflix I'm gonna
go to flappers and watch because I
didn't want to think about it that means
I gotta get up like at 7:00 or 7:30 take
a shower and not eat I don't think you
could even drink coffee you drink black
coffee with your blood pressure
medication I got a drive down there an
empty stomach to give blood that's
torture give them blood on a full
stomach that's one thing I could do that
with my eyes closed it's giving blood on
an empty stomach
eat some mushrooms challenge yourself
challenge myself enough right I love the
challenge myself at the [ __ ] doctor's
office down even me you have no idea
like everything about the doctor bothers
me I like him well I have a doctor I
have to like the doctor and trust them
the first couple of times I'm gonna will
standoffish
I'm in love her for sleep apnea I might
listen I ain't gonna [ __ ] with you
people if there's a needle involved I
don't want to even talk to you people
don't know there's no needles and Bob
that's the only reason why I ain't got
my sleep apnea treated at that time I
was really bad
now I'm gonna try to breathe I bring the
iPad I don't get too high the night
before so there's no misunderstandings I
don't get hired all that morning I don't
get high at all well speaking of like
canceling things like what would make
you guys cancel the show cuz I I could
feel this cold coming on
I'm when I supposed to leave on Friday I
was like I can't cancel I'm not gonna
can't like if you guys ever had to
cancel just show know I've always worked
through it even with food poisoning even
with flus I've done it uh it sucks you
should you should just start like you
know taking all the vitamin C and water
and sleeping for the next three days
well with me it was always considering
the situation I always considered the
situation like I think I got sick one
New Year's and had a cancel on job I'm
the feature actor you know you're the
feature act that's a complete different
thing you know when you're sick you call
me and go I don't feel good tonight then
we get a feature act anywhere in 20
minutes you know um seal stretch or
something like that for me now if I'm
coughing and whatever and I'm gonna give
them a bad show I'll cancel but anything
else I gotta move forward a little
detailing love a temperature emotions
you know think about Brody dying on a
Friday every comic in America that we
know how to perform that Friday night
something how you have to learn how to
overcome that stuff like when something
bad like that happens you have to rush
to the stage to you know so it doesn't
overpower you and that's what I had to
do room when Brody at that Friday I mean
every that Friday I started feeling bad
for myself for a second like a what is
that it every other comic in America is
going up on stage tonight how do you
think they feel sometimes in the fact
you'd just imagine you didn't you have
like a Icehouse chronicles that night
yeah we had a I saw Joe there was also a
lot of you know just imagine being an
audience member though that Friday going
to see a show and all the comics cuz I
talked a lot of comics
like Esther that had to go up and
perform and it was hard for all of them
and I can't even imagine what the
audience was like what is going on here
this is a weird night to be at a comedy
club but it was hard I when I went up I
almost lost it a few times it's been up
and down for me ever since though like
I'll be fine for three days and then out
of nowhere just my whole days ruined
well I spoke about grief on the podcast
Sunday and how people grieve we all
grieve differently I tell you what it
didn't bother me the first week
it didn't bother me the second week it
bothered me last week
last week to have a little I had a
couple different things going on in my
life but I was hot about and when I
searched to see what the problem might
thing like both people cool with me now
and I think it was because of the brony
situation I didn't know how to express
myself so I called it out on two
different situations that were going on
in my business aspect I got told a
little misunderstanding room and I think
it was to do with Brody like it comes
for me it comes out in different ways
you know that's why I said there's an
anger issue involved with grieving when
there's a suicide involved because at
one point you do get mad at that person
somewhere along Kawana they could be
under six months but nine months or a
year later or it could be three years
later you know even my mother who didn't
commit suicide I felt a little bit mad
at her for like a year in it like a year
I was like [ __ ] that [ __ ] you know how
can she live and not take care of
herself to have heart you know
but then you really just you empathize
with that person and then it goes away
and then you accept it for this it's we
I got your talking and I had a family
members pass away but up until a couple
years ago I didn't have friends pass
away like that's a weird thing as an
adult having friends pass away
unexpectedly and it's uh
it really takes out of you like it's
it's different you know guys you watch
the news everybody watches the news we
read Yahoo
and you look at things in life and you
go wow that's [ __ ] up thank God that
won't happen to me and then one day you
go to a concert in Vegas a
country-western concert Sunday night and
you're getting [ __ ] shot at you know
I mean you have to appreciate all the
moments and you always have to be
prepared for that situation you know
like we live in a world now that we
could be at a carnival and somebody
starts shooting we're gonna be at a
comedy show somebody starts shooting
will you be in a rouse and somebody
starts shooting the same thing as with
death you know Chris Cornell died hung
himself
it bothered us we were fans of Chris
Parnell and Soundgarden then the other
kid on himself and it bothered us
because we were fans and what's that
band Arlington Park Linkin Park but
Brody was a backyard that's one of us
I'm not talking about even like Robin
Williams on Robin Williams died he was a
Comedy Store guy but I saw I saw Robin
once or twice in my life I met him at
the stripe the him problem Brogan I did
I feel for it yeah that's when that's
when and enlightened me and then Rudy
Sarzo came on the podcast when we first
started the podcast and he spoke about
that with music with entertainment
hardest there's a thin line between
talent and mental health there's a very
very thin line and if there's a mental
health issue and we start arguing it
with the drugs to take care of it but
what no if we're trying to take care of
ourselves with the drugs they give us
and then which once you had alcohol and
drugs to the mix God knows where you're
gonna end up you know God knows we're
gonna what are you gonna end up you know
so that's when once Brody did it now I'm
concerned I I would I grew up and three
of my like good friends committed
suicide just growing up in high school
and Hayley yeah so I've had this like my
whole life people look killing it might
be my personality you know but but
but no no I so but this was the first
time out of all the people the first
time where I thought I had kind of a a
like I knew it was a problem where all
the other times it just came out of the
blue they killed himself had no like pre
like I had no idea what was going to
happen this time it's like oh you know
Brody suffers with you know mental
issues so I you know I got to check on
this guy and make sure he's okay and the
the crazy thing about him is he was okay
like recently he seemed like he was okay
like normal and and we're in the past
every time he was having an issue he
would be very Yeley and angry in in or
he would have his sunglasses on and be
very you know sad and this I saw him day
before he you know passed and he was
like hey Brody hey Brian how are
everything seemed normal
that's the thing that really drives me
crazy is because like because we all you
know we all love him and we would all
been there for him and we didn't feel
like we had any kind of warning at all
it just came out of nowhere that's the
part that that really digs into me that
that you know he was suffering and he
didn't let us know where you usually
lets us know everything about his life
it was really different then it uh four
o'clock on Thursday on Monday the day of
the we did the podcast Sunday night we
spoke about it for the first time on the
podcast I did not want to talk about the
first two or three weeks just there was
too much out there and they want to drag
a dog into the podcast but now was time
to acknowledge him and you know like I
said Sunday would piss me off the most
was his last 10 minutes you know his
last 10 minutes that's what got me that
none of us were there for him we don't
know if he went away in the morning but
we don't know if he decided to do this
at night you know you wake up all the
guys said they saw him the night before
and he was [ __ ]
so obviously I don't think he did it
that night I think he woke up to a wall
of [ __ ] and I read different things
online they've been disturbing some
people said he read the comments or a
special yeah I guess he was the latest
thing he was upset is that his special
which is on the Amazon I and really
captured the why we love Brody his
late-night spots at the Comedy Store and
it the whole special felt like you were
sitting at the Comedy Store you know in
the main room at 1:00 a.m. on a Saturday
or a Friday and there was a few comments
of people that you know just for like
hey you know rented it oh I don't know
what's going on here you know like just
typical normal white bread comedy people
saying I don't know what's going on this
guy seems like he's but that's the crazy
thing is is that when you first meet
Brody I think we all had the same kind
of like whoa this guy you know at first
it took you oh well Brody had a learning
curve like you had to like get to know
him to appreciate him when I first met
him I didn't even live here in
California
Joe this is like the first time I met
you too Joe and Doug was doing the
mansion show and Brody was the warm-up
guy the audience warm-up guy and I was
living in Ohio and I was like you know
why I want to fly out to LA see what
it's like and Joe has the man show so he
a Joe invited me to be able to watch the
man show like in the audience so I flew
out with a couple other people when the
audience ate a bunch of edibles and and
Brody was the audience warm-up guy and
Brody was like clap clap like we were
sitting like like third row or first row
or something like that and he was just
like hey you right there and for three
hours he screamed at us like clap I why
are you not clapping blah blah blah
doing hit all the stuff that I love him
for now but but when you're a high uh
guy and you have no idea what's going on
and you're like I was like scared of him
like hey like how it's like why is this
guy screaming at me I'm trying to clap
as much as I can and
in heaven then I think that I've met you
too you like you're on the show that
would famous thing where you popped out
naked and stuff like huh but then when I
came finally moved to LA the first night
I was at the Comedy Store Joe introduced
me to Mitzi and I was like talking to
Mitzi and I remember hearing Brody in
the background going yes and I was like
and I was like having a flashback like a
Vietnam flashback but there's the guy
that screamed at me all the time but
then after getting to know Brody now I
love all that [ __ ] about him now I look
back at him like oh my god I didn't get
it I'm laughing but I think people saw
his special and same first reaction they
had like why is this guy screaming at
everyone I don't get it one star Amazon
so Brody had been looking at all these
comments and focusing on the negativity
of him and I think that's that was
bugging him the last couple weeks of his
life that's the one thing that I have
been hearing it's a it was strength cuz
I first saw him I thought because I had
heard about him on podcast
I thought comedians were teasing him I
thought they were like kind of making
one of them a little bit behind his back
but the more that you met other people I
could you could feel the love people had
for Brody and I I don't know I mean you
guys know him better than I did
comments will get to me but I just know
you can't even read them do you think
you would yeah he he focused on all the
negativity all the time that was one of
his things like even just one word like
what what do you say that's not positive
I went into his apartment last night
his family had gone through all his
stuff and you know and his close friends
and stuff were you know just going you
know going through his things they're
donating a lot of his stuff but it was
my first time actually being in his
apartment and it was a very interesting
walking around and seeing what Brody
looked at every single day and and one
thing that was almost adorable was
everywhere you looked there was like
positive messages just like you like the
ones you see at like
you know the target where it says like
stay positive smile you know they're
just like little things everywhere and
it's bathroom it says you know have a
good day and you know every single step
you just had these positive messages
then you had pictures of him everywhere
there was one picture that was just him
this is I'm five and it was just a
picture of him at five years old and
next to his bed he had has this big
what's that thing with the Mexicans hit
a pinata a big cat pinata right next to
his bed on and then he Larry Bird on his
walls and all these little trinkets and
baseball toys and and but everywhere you
go in his house there was just little
signs that said smile positive energy
you know all the things that he
constantly says so it really made me go
wow he really not only says that but
lives that like he has to tell himself
every day to smile positive energy and
all that stuff and when he does and
that's the version I saw when I first
met me no the screaming and the you know
he really had was he so screaming lately
yeah yeah you still go yeah you still
he's still doing this thing you know but
it wasn't like it was like his act kind
of thing it wasn't the real screaming
thing like the video I showed you
earlier when we first started doing
podcasts it was called Brody Stephens
experiment and there was three of them
only ones available right now but the
other two he asked me to take him down
because he was going manic that's the
Brody that that when I first met him he
where he was screaming and everything
was bothering him he would hear a dog
barking why is the dog barking I can't
concentrate in just yelling and stuff it
was really interesting the why I just
found those two episodes and it was
really interesting to watch because I
could tell something was not right with
him and that after those episodes is
when he checked in which it was that
2013 11 I think that's when he had the
episode yeah the exact producing his
yeah yeah show on HBO enjoy
it was called I think it was enjoy it
was it and that that was right before
all that happen like literally like
maybe a week before it happened where he
got checked into the psych ward and and
they started filming the show for enjoy
it what do you guys think because I
think it to me he was just very well
known for his audience warm up I don't
think he I think it bothered him a
little bit do you think he enjoyed the
audience warm up someone i the last show
i did with him someone brought him up as
like the best audience won't guy I've
ever seen he liked it yeah I don't think
he doesn't like the title but I think he
liked doing it he liked doing it yeah he
was very very good
I met Brody in Seattle and at first I
used to break his balls and call into
the hemant a nACCHO public-access yet he
go Diaz I know what you 50-year old man
and he was said to me and then we did
get found all those tapes by the way he
had all of them at his apartment which
ones all the public access show every
single one of them no I told I told him
like you gotta digitize these you gotta
put these out there were boxes each one
labeled like episode 1 2 3 so hopefully
we get to see those someday so I you
know at the end the ground it was a ball
busters paradise we'll all opened my cos
we all ran in a pack me him Josh Gavin
there was a bunch of us that ran six
seven deep and we detained him Josh wolf
dana mark Madison nice guys you know but
at first I didn't know how to take them
and then I saw the other side of him I
saw he was a sweet sweet guy so he asked
me for advice I talked him into going to
New York and we kept in touch very
lightly he was living in Brooklyn you
know in all this [ __ ] and then one
minute the culture noises [ __ ] up to
the gills I'm slow
and I'm there with the stripper and she
had her a little hooker friend with her
so I said hook her up with Brody shut up
and Brody had the Volvo we were so
[ __ ] up that he made me drive he
showed up at the Comedy Store in the war
back to coach noises and he made me
drive it on his coat out of my mind and
he had Superunknown and that cassette
deck and I took it out cuz I wanted it
for the car I mean it was just in the
next day he called me oh did you take my
soprano and yeah [ __ ] yeah and all this
[ __ ] that was the one story I wanted you
to say it I just very Brooke what was it
with in Seattle or something were you
kidnapped him in his own car
I put him in the back of the car and I
told the shut the [ __ ] that I could make
it to Gig Harbor in an hour and a half
and he didn't believe I was doing 19 and
he kept saying normal people don't live
like well where I saw like this whole
time I just thought he was a kid I loved
them like I liked him you know and he
was entertaining but once we were on the
best damn sports show I would get there
the tape in the afternoon and those kids
would get in there and it was the best
warm-up I had ever seen in my life
because it was a warm-up that nobody
warms up people like that everybody is
very clean the warm-up guy from Joe
Rogan show Newsradio Joe Hayes they used
to call him captain date-rape oh my god
cuz the guy wore a jacket he was really
creepy he grabbed grandmother's hands
and [ __ ] and then Bill Maher had KP
Anderson KP still around
you know I just bumped into him KP and
there was another choice to go to a CBS
show and their warm-up was just horrific
but once you saw Brody do warm up it was
something that like you said people will
look at me know what the [ __ ] is this
you don't want to laugh don't you know
then he would tell you something obscure
I'm a model and where would you model
Pakistan Pakistan and you know and these
people like is he being serious
like there's so many nights me and then
John Kruk would just watch him do
warm-up and how like Brody just and the
people would be petrified mmm patricide
you're right I forgot all about that
quality yet because he wasn't your
traditional high it's like seeing
Holtzman lot like Brian Holtzman one of
the funniest comedians in the world that
no one knows about and if you see him
you might be like what the same kind of
reaction but if you get it you're seeing
some of the best comedy you ever seen
yeah he was there yeah he's so beautiful
but really is Brody was the best part of
the oddball tour that I went to go see
really yeah oh yeah oh you got to see my
oddball oh yeah he was on the small
stage and then probably for like the
beginning part when no comedy was going
on and I went I went the year it was
like Gaffigan Sarah Silverman the
Nerdist guy plunk you guys name right
now it doesn't matter and Brody would go
up the party went up there and my ex and
I like he was that he'd all we would
talk about the whole time like the whole
the rest of the show was just okay and
brought it brought he kills it the whole
time it was awesome so he was on the
side stage he hosted that but then he
was I think he warmed up the main stage
to if I'm not from remembering correctly
yeah he was a different type of [ __ ]
breathe man and he just kept pounded in
listen after he had the episode and
whatever I pulled him aside I talked to
him so that we are I'm obliged I
searched him for what the bust his balls
like makes you don't have a weapon on
you [ __ ] and listen man looking at it
all over again that's the last call I
thought I was ever gonna get especially
even have even after the show I think I
knew I knew Brody had his little mental
things but so do a lot of people but I
never expected to him does to us one
never never I think that's a took people
you know you to call me and said he buy
a car got
to bid or he was in the car accent I get
that I never understood this one type
thing for probably yeah and like I said
the last ten minutes if he knew how
everybody felt that Monday night if he
knew how people had been feeling the
last three weeks you know it's it's just
weird it's just but we move on like I
said as comedians listen man well you
know you were saying something before I
don't mean to be rude to you laughing
like that but things are gonna happen in
your comic career there's gonna be one
day that you're in [ __ ] Poughkeepsie
New York about to go up and you're gonna
get a call that a loved one is dead and
you can't quit you can't quit it's kind
of the feelings are over gonna I'm gonna
overpower you I was very fortunate I was
very you know it's a bittersweet feeling
for me because in 1995 I had this silent
war going I love my wife and I would
realize that after I would drop the baby
off my daughter at that time I would
drive like two blocks down the road and
mentally breakdown I would cry and I'd
be angry at myself and and this went on
for about two months and Wednesdays I
would just go home and get Chinese food
delivered then I would just sit there no
TV I would just sit there not write
jokes I would just sit there and then
wait two hours and order cocaine that
was that was what I did on Wednesday
nights but I forced myself I said I'm
not doing this no more for me to become
a really really good comic I have to
learn how to do comedy upset so I forced
myself to do you know that Wednesday
room I was talking about here that the
guy was the Elvis impersonator with the
spaghetti or something that was the
Wednesday night and there was club 56 on
Wednesday night so I would force myself
so yeah I'm mad that I would I would
look up at that guy with the Elvis suit
on saying it and I'm a god I can't
believe I'm opening for this kind of
Wednesday night but at least I wasn't in
my apartment so what I would do was I
would drop her off at 7:00
I would drive up maybe a mile and I
would have to join the ashtray and I
would smoke the joy I would cry a little
bit but I was dropping off my daughter I
would smoke the joy and then I would
force myself to go to Carly first couple
times I hit a bag of dick but then after
a while I started getting better at him
better at him better and I had just
worked an avenue net now can that affect
me again if somebody closed something
close to me I'm still able to do comedy
because I've learned how to shut it off
there was a lot of people who called me
that day
after four o'clock I stopped taking
calls that day because I knew that what
the call was for so I just took the
phone put it on off and put it in a
charger and I went through the other
room with Kate saying I had my food in
the bedroom when I was outside the
living room with Kate eating cheese and
she liked that room service because I
didn't want to feel bad I didn't want
people to keep [ __ ] reminding me like
before eight o'clock and then when I
woke up Saturday had morph I'd call from
206 so there was a newspaper trying to
call now because they left a message so
I got that Saturday morning hi the
Seattle some more know if you have any
words for Rowley Stevens we got your
number from such-and-such I was like I'm
not calling you like I know I'll deal
with it accomplished all so I didn't
really when I got back Sunday was the
first time so that was fine with it
and I'm and I called Josh wolf and I
could see that he it was starting to hit
him because we had pushed it aside we
said [ __ ] it let's do comedy let's worry
about these two shows and we'll worry
about brownie on the way back Sunday and
that's when the plane ride back was
where I let it digest I cried a little
more I went home I called Josh and then
I can't called you we all spoke and
that's it you know that was basically it
I'm sorry this had to happen to a bunch
of young guys at the store so they
weren't you young comics out of
witnesses but we all do this you know
this happened that our
yard this is not good so now we have to
be a little stronger as comics now we
know that this could happen again but we
can't let it happen you know Robin
Williams and now Brody Stephens so what
can we do to not let this happen again
this is what I said yeah they've no more
texting you got a call three people a
week just pick three people you know hi
Evie right now we could pick a sheet of
paper and each of us could give it to
one another
I could write three names here but I
could see doing that before Brody
Stephens oh yeah
hundred names I can name three names off
the top of my head right now
mmm just from me being around the store
in the comedy game and seeing people at
different clubs there's three people I'm
worried about more that I was worried
about Brody Stephens so for this not now
we have to make sure this doesn't happen
again all right it's it's hard to
constantly deal with this in the comedy
community too it seems like it's
non-stop because we're such a large
family and so tight you know and there's
so many people seems like comedians are
drawn to depression and and sadness and
you know a that's here that series
pissed me off a little bit what does
pissed me off it and lighten me a little
bit you know the dark side of comedy and
it was just a bunch of comics talking
about this drug really was yeah and I
watch it you see they've had a long
maybe last year or something like that
and I'd listen to what they had to say I
had a lot of you know concerns my wife
goes to bed at 8:30 sometimes 9:00 the
baby goes to bed at 8:30 and some nights
yeah you go a little computer room and
you put music on and you write jokes oh
you look at your schedule and you tell
her how you're gonna do it but at the
same time that's when that [ __ ] could
happen go on YouTube look at one of your
videos some guy calls you a fat [ __ ]
your waste of life whatever I could see
all that transpiring into but that's why
I don't read the comments I gave up
reading Thomas four or five years ago on
YouTube and then when you look at just
pick any song just pick a great band and
pick a song and go to it on YouTube
I was watching saw remains the same last
night it's got six million views well
it's got 480 dislikes so four hundred
eighty thousand hey the bugs up sorry if
they hate legs up they're gonna hate us
yeah you know not that's what makes the
world go round
just and then everybody's a little
everything you do I love when people
make a comment on you know on Twitter to
Facebook sometimes you get upset because
you're like I'm trying to provide the
service I'm trying to help people right
and you gotta [ __ ] break my balls but
somebody sometimes you know look at
where that person's coming from you know
no he's in a basement he's just [ __ ]
looking around easy to get attention
[ __ ] him so it's better not even to pay
attention to those things they create
doubt and it's done by people if you had
a life you wouldn't have time to write a
stupid comment if you understand
humanity you wouldn't have fun there's a
lot of [ __ ] on like online that's tons
of [ __ ] I don't like you don't see me
[ __ ] write negative comments I just
switched and just click the channel or
don't watch it that's it what to put
somebody down for somebody tryin go [ __ ]
yourself yeah what do you do what do you
do you actually I'm here well listening
and looking the quit look at those
YouTube comments from time to time on
anybody whether it's Rogen look you ever
see Rogen's [ __ ] Instagram you want
to [ __ ] shoot him
like we're gonna post something about a
fight and they're talking about [ __ ]
that do it fight like that you know
they're in stimulating you're like I
feel bad for Joe like here's a guy that
works hard he's a smart guy he reads
[ __ ] books he does research for his
podcast and you break his [ __ ] balls
too
okay they what kind of person are you
you know so 14 year old at Quiznos just
pissed off at light
you know is that's what I always think
of like when you read these negative
comments like who's the person that's
writing this what kind of life do they
live it's just I feel sad you had a life
you would have fun right exactly we're
being negative for her yeah are you that
angry or if a person and you don't know
what type of dead person's happening
very scary you don't know what that
person's going through you don't know
what happened with his wife before he
left the house his wife hasn't sucked
his dick because he doesn't have a job
you know when you see these these
careless [ __ ] murders on the news
you're like the person died because the
person was having a bad day or because
you know it's just sad it's [ __ ] very
sad mental health you know you look at
[ __ ] leave here at night and go onto
that bridge over there how many homeless
people live over there tons now there's
a lot though did she have you [ __ ]
seen that at night they're walking out
in the street yeah yeah they're the one
guy was sweeping garbage onto the street
you go onto the bridge on Chandler the
bridge every by [ __ ] the floor the
open mic over there yeah that [ __ ]
bridge on Laurel Canyon they got people
living under there
you know there's and I can listen I know
the difference between them there's a
big black dude that walks around here 6
6 to 9 d what do you want to do every
time I see him I give him a 20 I haven't
seen him in about three weeks
because I always say if me and my wife
getting the beef I just sick [ __ ] this
guy I talked to him a few times he's the
next 8 yeah what was the the conflict in
like the vein these are the one that the
911 that one Iraq or or Odessa has it
storm he's one of those guys that walks
around so I know you could kill him
[ __ ]
yeah sorry Tom I see that's a good
that's a good move man the best my
future my security he's walking past my
block I'm gonna to fight with two Puerto
Ricans he's jumping in that [ __ ] guy
yeah but no I know the between mental
health and [ __ ] being a scumbag and I
know the temperature mental health and
being a [ __ ] [ __ ] he'll there's a big
[ __ ] difference man
but we live with it all I want is uh the
comics to heal correctly you know I want
the comics
everybody's gonna heal from this is
gonna take a while yeah
I could feel it last at the store you
know that there was still remnants of it
so yeah it's still going on it's still
going on
and a lot of these young comics that
it's their first major yes
one two yes so you know for similarly
Jimmy Schubert he was here with [ __ ]
Kennison died right like it all those
people like that that's you know I was
here for Maryland I was here for Freddy
so no no I miss man miss Marilyn - I
miss Freddy from time to time I put the
store you know Brody's gonna be a hard
one you know then I didn't see him as
much as I talked to him I would talk to
Brody on the phone and then him and Burt
Lee and Burt would tell me about his
videos at Starbucks around the corner I
would run into him all the time and then
he stopped going unfortunately but
that's that's one thing I'm very
thankful for is the podcast and the
videos and yeah we have a lot of content
that's one good thing you know that's
because he did nothing but record
himself and make sure you know I have
like all the Brody and Esther podcasts I
I have so many things to go back and
watch because I I watched one the other
day and it was just thankfully I forgot
all about this you know when you show me
a woman before then once I close on the
[ __ ] cry yeah I don't want to watch
that it was a it's I don't know it for
me it's right because I I came into this
as a fan and it was I didn't I do regret
and this is one thing that I'm I'm
trying to take from it is I never got to
see him do his late night at the main
room oh really I didn't that's the one
I'm very regretful for that so I but I
got to do shows with the belt like the
second more I did that did shows with
him everywhere and that was with you at
the ice house and that was great but uh
I'm looking one thing I'm trying to take
from him is from this is to is to go out
and see this stuff not wait and I'll be
like I'll see that sometime like I like
everyone got to see that and then I I'm
bummed out that I didn't get to go see
and with like the and
one thing I learned I didn't realize he
didn't know how to play the drums I
forget who I was talking to now he does
no no I'm pretty sure I think it was
either Josh wolf was saying one of the
videos I was watching that he played it
on the chairs but he was supposed to be
in a music video and they gave him a
real set of drums he's like I don't know
how to play these well I mean he
probably well I don't know because like
it when you have you have a whole drum
kit in front of me that's way different
than like being able to like if you had
like if he had a drum in front of him he
could play drums yeah I don't know about
that but I used to love is his
periscopes he would he would play music
and he would like zoom around his room a
little bit for the whole time like he
called like a junior jam I just a little
he would call like he had like an intern
that was setting up it wasn't just him
be who turn no who's just it was saying
it he would tweeted he be like the
interns going to Starbucks for a coffee
run you'll just be good with the entire
time what I loved it one of the things
that when I was at his apartment they
were I you know like what should they
donate or why should I get and he had
its box of all his drum pads and I was
like you know why I don't want them just
throw this away so I have all his little
drum pads and his little germ that you
would do with the little speaker that ya
Ashton's stuff like that I think I'm
gonna just hang it up at the studio or
something like all his pads
toured with it he would bring a road
what did you good so you took the drums
I have it like a slow drum pads
it's little shakers that's just you know
and all that stuff is a little bluetooth
thing that he would play - because
that's what I used to love it's watching
him just sit there and play drums and
his thing and a little bouncing ball
yeah totally I also I also have a lot of
stuff that I think I'm ready scan in and
and make it available to friends and
family and fans like old setlists in in
like like I have set lists from like
2020 years ago you know over 15 years
ago it just says nipples
beard scar you know
in you know it's fun to see like setlist
or where he had scratched off he's like
too dirty
like it's so adorable like looking
through all this stuff and his little
notes and stuff so I'm ready try to get
that out there for people to look at and
download or whatever it's very hard for
me to comprehend so it's very hard to
explain to people that this calmly life
has been tremendous like this has just
been tremendous and this calmly saved my
life you know calmly put a smile on my
face calmly made me fall in love with
something that I knew was there but I
never knew I was capable of doing like I
saw it in the movies and all these
things that I'm doing I wanted to do you
know and now I got the opportunity to go
I don't really want to do movies no boy
you know unless it's the movie I don't
want to do this but you know last week I
went to Houston and I was fine you know
I wasn't thinking about Brody I was just
looking forward to Monday I was looking
forward to a couple things and then
something life just stops you you know a
lady came to the show and she came you
hug you know she goes do you're my man
you try to be nice and polite and I will
not that Thursday and took some pictures
she goes I was at the show the night you
took your dick out and chased Rogan and
it's just like I forgot that whole
memory like that whole thing had been I
don't even think Joe and I had spoken
about it well you wouldn't use some of
the same time I don't feel like it I
didn't know the witness it was a fear
factor and he had gotten down there to
promote his CD so we worked Addison
Friday Saturday Sunday and then we
rented a car and drove to Houston on
Monday and Tuesday and Monday we went to
a record store we bought clothes you
know he bought me clothes yeah
was you know you went to a record store
whatever you picked up three CDs they
would pay for this [ __ ] so I picked up
Freddie Prinze live from Chicago and
some Redd Foxx out for something and me
and him drove to Houston at this time
Joe did not get out so it was the
longest ride of my [ __ ] life in those
days it wasn't like going to call let me
just let me join that side yeah he would
get mad and get mad at you yeah so I was
smoking cigarettes he let me smoke up in
the car with the window kind of guy that
was cool that was cool he was having a
good time yeah it was first on the
headline like he was I think News Radio
had just wrapped up and he still really
wasn't into fifth factor but Warner
Brothers and giving him money to do it
out and the album release party was in
Houston that's what it was
the album release party was at a sports
bar Warner Brothers did another sports
bar and we were like why would you do it
at a sports bar and Stella laughs stop
so we ended up going to a sports bar
like eight people showed up to get their
CD signs of their album signed it was me
in the middle with my dick out and then
Kapaun hang down yeah so that's why he
took me with him and then Tuesday we did
them open mic Monday night in Houston
which Houston was known for the best
open mic in the country eight to [ __ ]
had laughs and so last time and then we
went out we went out with Mungo and
everybody outlaw Dave the DJ so we ended
up at Lola's in Montrose area a [ __ ]
bar that had no windows you go in there
you're like hi I like a makers mark and
they're looking at though it's 7:00 to
7:00 night mmm that's it we got seven to
seven in Heinekens what's your choice
you didn't go in there in order to drink
they told you where you would drink it
so you might go in there one of the
[ __ ] martini and they're like nah
it's greyhound line tonight walking
grapefruit juice I don't like grapefruit
juice then it's vodka night you know
venez vodka night well I don't like
vodka well we got [ __ ] but what's the
beer they drink in Houston
- item yeah we got Scheider that's it so
I took Joe then it was path and you know
in those days I can only hold that so
long so I waited for Joe to get drunk a
little drunk which he was very hard to
do in those days just one shot like
where he wouldn't pay attention and I
went and got a package mm-hmm well and
I'm doing the package without Lord Dave
and I could tell Joe knows I'm [ __ ]
coked up being outlaw there's gotta be
three other people that don't [ __ ]
coke around Joe and it two or three in
the morning and outside of we decide
who's what am I gonna do tomorrow night
I'm like I know what you wanna do is
this is so much fun it was [ __ ] let's
do a free show so we left outlaw day we
went got breakfast without law till
about 4:00 then we went back to our
hotel rooms and then went back to radio
Nate and he told the city of Houston he
was doing a free show he called mark
Babbitt woke mark Babbitt up and said
I'm doing radio get somebody down there
to the to the club to answer the phone
to put the names on the list and we did
a free [ __ ] show it's great and then
Joe went up there and the whole life
stop had the same thing that the Comedy
Store does I could really get to you
from the original room behind people
don't know that I can go if I go in the
back bar mm-hmm this is a hallway back
there like you could slip into that
stage yeah and I would go behind that
stage and open up the curtain naked and
flip up in the closing knock again so I
went into the back of the array of the
laughs stop and I forgot that they had
done improv there I'm like Sunday nights
was in probably some group would come in
and they'd have whatever the [ __ ] you
call it like stunts will he call those
props tops props and they had like one
of those King Tut [ __ ] things so I
took my shirt mm-hmm put the King Tut
helmet on and Joe was on stage and I'm
like he's gonna get pissed really gonna
get pissed if I do this so I waited
towards the end of his set and I [ __ ]
came out there [ __ ] it somebody taped
it the place went [ __ ] I'm serious
the place went bananas let me know I
remember look into the back of the last
I remember there was a long row in the
laughs stop you all had to sit together
if you took the last table it was a
great seat it was just a row with 60
people shot sat it was like going to
church without the middle so it was just
a long thing with tables and I'll never
forget people standing back there
clapping like looking back there and I'm
naked from the pants down and people
were just on their cushions clapping I
was like holy [ __ ] and that lady showed
me the picture and said that was the
night oh wow that had to be 18 [ __ ]
years ago and then you came on board
then I started recording all those Joe
was traveling with six [ __ ]
time human being in San Jose and Denny
would show up with half the jujitsu
school
Ali and him and Henny Brown would take
their shoes off in jujitsu and San Jose
what about the time with the Tempe
donated that the fight off the fight off
yeah what go you have no idea you guys
have no idea and Adam was there at the
time he was a waiter he had away the
waiter the general manager the comedy
store was a way that the Tempe era and
there was a guy that was like a purple
belt one night so I haven't ate one out
of first Indian guy not like saving like
good guy yeah nobody was thrown punches
got it but in those daily tournament no
in the middle of the lobby in the middle
row every [ __ ] night every [ __ ]
night with any problem those days so
Denny would come Denny was 16 mm-hmm 15
and we would sneak them into drinks
about the into cobs yeah upstairs then
we ate so many chicken things that the
people at cops told us no more and I
went off that's your best chicken
tenders you ever had so we go I mean oh
it was three in order we put in
ari that's right nobody remembers that
word quit your Rogen we're getting the
[ __ ] out of here
this [ __ ] won't give us some
more chicken strip and he's like all
right all right all right I was only
playing with you guys
Johnny Appleseed or whether he was a
Johnny Appleseed know what was the guy
okay then there was Tom Sawyer I'm so he
either had the crush on Joe they knew
went downstairs the one day and he
showed up with a two-seater @pf cruiser
oh yeah
nobody remembers that he will always
want to be alone with Joe so Joe would
always bring you and Duncan number the
time you and Duncan had of that oh yeah
that's the [ __ ] stab me with a pen you
through the you through the [ __ ] hat
out of that you came down to you I thank
you for [ __ ] taking me the radio also
the hat flies across the table you [ __ ]
[ __ ] tremendous holy [ __ ] what about
the hotel we stayed at where that was
supposed to be like a ship oh yeah I
still stayed there I just I like I've
stayed there couple years ago was it
chowder place above the chatter yeah
last year the Bluebird Bay whatever I
remember when they found the body across
the street in a suitcase in the water in
the ocean there's a person all chopped
up in that I woke up with there was cops
everywhere I could go outside and smoke
a joint I thought they were there for me
we had a run where what about the time
we were in the hotel room and the hotel
the kids sprayed the [ __ ] spray ah
fire extinguisher yeah we're all gonna
die you wrote a bit about that yeah
that's right that was the worst because
that's a bad I kept looking the alarm
was going off and I get up and I'm like
if you think I'm leaving this hotel
early
you're [ __ ] crazy it seemed like a
real fire too because it was so much
okay because if I opened up the hallway
guys and I saw people running and I just
slammed the door I'm like if this is a
false alarm
I'm gonna beat the [ __ ] so finally it
was like at 4:45 my flight was like at
7:00
anyway so my god dammit
I'm looking out the window and seeing
people I've been I'm like oh [ __ ] this
might be [ __ ] serious yeah so I
packed up my sleeping machine I was
leaving the more than any way you guys
were staying that's what I would work
Sundays and Joe would get is some smart
so ahead of the time us Oh about working
Sunday I think you made that rule for
most comics nowadays like yeah no
there's no reason to work my Sunday
leave me the [ __ ] alone so that's
Saturday night I look out and there's
people downstairs I open up the door and
people kill themselves to run down the
stairs oh yeah I was about to throw
myself out of the window and just start
punching a wall right I'm sitting there
going you know what I am NOT in the
[ __ ] mood attack but once I looked
out again I go no this is serious there
could be a fire but I did smell no smoke
so I packed up my sleep apnea bag I took
my little bag and I went to the elevator
and pressed it the elevator opens right
up you that's right yeah because there
was a spiral staircase like everything
12 floors why are these people running
but you could take the elevator I would
love to see the face on the people in
the lobby when the elevator door and
they just looked at me like because they
made you go outside oh yeah so now I
come on I don't see none of my friends
but I look up and I see Rogan Segura and
you on a street corner looking up and
they're like what a [ __ ] of you bit yeah
wasn't there in there was something
behind like a lady a stripper or
something remember there was like behind
us the woman came out or something happy
it was a girl hooker hope the Chinese
took a place yeah ready we used to
[ __ ] go on the road with six of us
I still remember get the big table like
at papadelis mmm we go to hostages
we met hotel is there across the
slightest all Waga tree that's the best
what we had was Houston
yeah that's to what the picture means
like this the pool when are we good ari
took of me that's an that's what
now that's Phoenix that that weird
Resort with the waterfalls in jenna
jameson and all that stuff remember they
had that was the all the one that was
the crazy one up at the rocks yeah all
the rocks you're like gonna rock you
sure there's something that was mookie
of that is I don't think we could
[ __ ] go away yeah you had all this
before
uber yeah you had a walk down the road
with snakes cross it yeah there was no
place to get like water I better go to
the [ __ ] lady going hi where's there
a restaurant around here and they're
like yeah walk down the dirt road you
gotta wait take a car or call a cab or
something I'm like [ __ ] that I'm gonna
walk she's like you better not there's
rattlesnakes eases yeah I didn't like
that place at all the brute the boot
three routes but the the Butte yeah
the boots yes beautiful town I an extent
the area but it's just so away from
everything yeah so I I don't know if the
lady was messing with me I don't think
she said how far was you I wouldn't walk
out there and I'm like why not she goes
because it's rattlesnake season or
something we had it was any minute and
then we had a way for Jonah wake up and
he had the rental car and then we'd all
good man you know if you really think
about it on paper like the thing with me
and Rogan was probably 99 and 2000 and
the stuff with you you said how to be
2004 really yeah so much before the
longest shot we were hanging out yeah
then we would do it all that [ __ ] but
you would texting me yeah
and I would chase you around yeah yeah
yeah and then Atlanta is what we called
Duncan the Atlanta punchline is where we
call Duncan made the tape of me accused
them oh yeah yeah yeah really bad
outside so tannic it was really humid
there okay right that's so much I hate
that clip because Monday morning we had
a drive during the [ __ ] rush hour and
it was like an hour and a half drive to
the [ __ ] Airport and it says the
Atlanta punchline but it's really not
Lana yeah it's like an hour outside of
land Oh No so you would have to drive a
[ __ ] hour on Monday more that's when
I stopped on listen Monday's I just
figured out that's when you are yelling
at Rogen remember the video of you he's
screaming at Rogen
I think that was Texas oh well we had
the van okay when he had the white van
he insisted on [ __ ] renting a car
every [ __ ] time we went I would say
them Joe you don't know where you're
[ __ ] going
why do you went to car and he would get
that Siri whatever that lady's name is
not a class it was it was like first
gps's
and boëthius would be driving me [ __ ]
crazy with the GPS was very good making
left in 3000 seconds right in [ __ ] in
22 minutes and I'm like guys knock it
off with the rental then I'm [ __ ]
rental on Sunday we had a ring back the
rental car and [ __ ] walk with all
that [ __ ] luggage to the everyone one
day he parked far away to break my balls
you know he was my brother
and I couldn't say that dumb in front of
people but I would call him up in his
hotel room you next time you make me
walk that floor with [ __ ] love it I
will flatten the [ __ ] tonight we will
[ __ ] be hoofing it back to the
airport you understand me you parked in
front of the [ __ ] hotel from now on
and let us out without luggage to meet
him in tight with Johnny shape we're
gonna be sick we're gonna [ __ ] two miles
to the hotel walk with our [ __ ]
luggage and the heat of the [ __ ]
summer you're out of your mind man
Johnny shape you know it just it just
looking at those pictures and talking
about all this there's a video I made a
long time ago when we were in
Philadelphia me you Joe and I think
maybe Tate Ari no Ari I think it's
called if you type in Joe show
Philadelphia but that had the GPA I put
the GPS in there for you at the
beginning of it cuz it's like up I had
turn left epic and you like it cuz I cuz
it was all about that same it used to
[ __ ] drive me crazy
oh that [ __ ] drove me [ __ ] crazy
the computers the same cell phones oh
yeah you used to hate cell phones
texting I remember before remember when
I used to have the laptop up at Cobbs
then we're okay like grab me like nah
turn
things heard that [ __ ] thing off you
know what that happened that was my 90th
day off cocaine yeah
I quit cocaine that November 15th and we
went to cops at the beginning of the
year and I didn't like being on like I
was raised that if the phones on the
hook they could even hate mm-hmm so in
those days you guys would open that
[ __ ] computer up and I was petrified
of it petrified that the CIA was
watching me along with the cocaine and
all that [ __ ] and I told him one day I
go Brian closed that [ __ ] computer
and Brian would put the camera on me and
I [ __ ] broke the computer Roby came
up Rogan had to pay for the [ __ ]
computer he didn't talk to me for three
weeks and [ __ ] what'd I tell you what
the scariest time ever was that tape you
made of me JD is ready to die I think I
think that's still available on YouTube
that's terrible I watched that like four
years ago when I was like boy that's the
life I I it that was a rough time man
because the hell you know that
I really thought you hadn't made me
believe that you were dying like you
said your spirit left you and you just
like you didn't want to live anymore
and I remember making that video like my
mission in that video was to document
what you were going through and try to
like show you that we love you and
everything's going to be okay and happy
that's why if you watch the video it
starts off so sad and depressing and
like you're talking about how you want
to die and then it's you on the plane
singing on American Airlines singing we
were in that fake band ten inch screws
or whatever screws instead of Nine Inch
Nails
we all had wigs on and you were hot by
the way how did we I thought we were all
gonna get arrested when we did that
because twice on the way there in the
way back you we somehow tricked the
stewardess into letting you get on the
intercom
and singing biggie one of those it was
one of those in the middle of song you
go rogue on anyone race
the way a favorite line no get I want to
raise cuz Brogan's had to move you get
up dancing I'll give you a raise
yeah you did and that was the one of the
most amazing and skiff shocking cuz this
was after 9/11 so the fact that they let
you like take over an intercom system oh
my god I was rapping and you're rapping
you're like who is this calling me it's
6:00 in the morning songs and one of
them you know that [ __ ] Vegas thing
ready to die I can't tell you the damage
I did that week I got a call from one of
my best friends ever
and he goes we're going on to Vegas a
bunch of us on this date and I go that's
crazy cuz I'm gonna be their tour that
day we were at the House of Blues I
think Friday and Saturday right or was
it
no I Friday you were sad Friday was the
thing yeah and sadly was the UFC yeah
that's good first of all I had dug the
longest yards we talked about this year
then I was [ __ ] depressed because
nothing came out of it [ __ ] Chris
Rock got to show [ __ ] the black guy
got a show or sudden the other guy got
big and the only people who stayed the
same with me Lobo and [ __ ]
dictatorial everybody else got something
along is she
everybody everybody everybody hates
chris Cheezburger Eddie he's bringing
Terry Crews I mean you know go so all
these people I had everything I got
nothing nobody [ __ ] call me I was
thinking about Quentin calmly but when I
would go to Vegas there was a kid that
would go to the UFC's and he was part of
the UFC like something he did something
for the UFC and every time he'd see me
look at me in the stands they go and
then he'd go like this like call me and
I think that that Thursday
I got his number that Thursday when you
made that tape this is no [ __ ] like we
got into town and I lost you guys like I
was like I don't feel good I'm gonna
stay in my room [ __ ] yeah I remember
this that guy brought up an eight ball
and he would bring up the come down
package was next to $10 it was to
vicodins to [ __ ] valentin good deal
so it was one hand for the package they
would deliver it to your door I think I
spent 600 hours that we can love coke
yeah I remember that weekend my friends
kept calling me gonna hey we're over
here these are my height these are my
friends from high school and they're
like we're over at this hotel we got a
free [ __ ] dinner come over and I go
be on in 10 minutes I would never show
and then they couldn't come to the show
because they were going to a bachelor
party and that's what happened that
Friday night it was like after I had
done to wait balls and I had done pills
to just straight now for the show like
this is this is when I was to the point
where I was slot until 6:00 and not
sleeping mmm I got was to that so when I
taped that that's after being up 48
hours you could see the bags under my
eyes how fat was that no guy it's
amazing god yeah the differences over
gone I couldn't even breathe yeah I
couldn't even breathe it was like I had
dirty pounds on my chest all the time
and I'll never forget talking like I was
serious like I was done by now he's done
like nothing happens with this movie I
can't stop snorting coke I can't stop
like alysha's getting worse guys like I
can't stop and Rogan wanted to pitch a
show about cold saving Joey Diaz yeah
when they come to my house and do blood
tests yeah it pissed the Bible and [ __ ]
like that and I was starting to get on
my nerves now remember don't know if you
remember yeah I don't want nobody taken
well yeah I remember the phone calls I
was yeah and nobody better come to my
[ __ ] house and wake me the [ __ ] up
well I'm gonna start shooting some
people like I was
we were we were about to do an
intervention yeah that's the white what
it was leading to and yes and it was
that bad I could feel it now how bad it
was and when I saw those tapes a couple
years ago I almost called you to say to
take him down but I didn't want to take
him down because I wanted to show people
that you could be in a horrible [ __ ]
spot anyway that was one of the worst
spots I was in my life like I had a
little bit of money like I was making a
little bit of money that much
now if it was going to blow but all it
was Baltimore I mean I couldn't control
it I could not control it I'd like to
know what year that was to see if we if
I was even on the heroine yet like there
was a time in that dark shadow that I
got into Hamel like I was doing [ __ ]
however I didn't know you did that yeah
well not even that wasn't that one
wasn't heroin the thing that you
convinced yourself would cheer yourself
on me laughs but it wasn't you know guys
you have to I wanted to take that down
in the worst way a couple years ago I
don't know leave it up cuz I want people
to see who the [ __ ] I was in 2000 it had
to be it looks like around 2010 2011 and
oh no no cuz I was still snorted I was
still snorted so it's gotta be earlier
than that yeah it's gotta be before
November 2000 it probably was February
or March of 2007 I was on my last leg I
really we just wanted to die and then
maybe a few weeks after that I saw the
Ray thing the movie about ray or
something yeah right but either ray come
out what unit ray can we gonna looking
up that Oh 404 so when I saw ray yeah
look at that look at that look how big
he is there yeah well remember Diana
Ross your voice is different oh my god
what are we doing that's that was the
wind Joe was doing push-ups with our
reporter and remember at the Houston
here's you to remember we sat outside
taste you're talking about mugging
[Laughter]
look at that [ __ ] look at that Big
Daddy shirt Big Daddies that used to
have that's all your every outfit every
out for the Hat was Big Daddy I was
spending all my money on coke the only
clothes that has Big Daddy sweats do
they even exist anymore no they got sold
and sold and sold until they finally
realized nobody wanted to be big daddy
don't worry so [ __ ] it's weird what
we used to wear I remember ice always
wear skin remember Stan yeah the skin
guys and I still have the Hat yeah I
still have one shirt attention they gave
us our first shirts for the church yeah
that kids still around
is it girlfriend died oh really I
dressed her so she died of like asthma
oh no really did crazy sick those guys
were great these to give us boxes a few
years he's still around he's in Vegas
he's a very good guy I like him
right bad I'm really sorry about Brody I
know what he meant to you and I'm really
sorry I know that I always tell my wife
when I died nobody's gonna suffer more
than read bad because I know he loves me
[ __ ] and he's got 2,000 pounds of video
of me he's like two million dollars now
as a hell now I'm really sorry about
Brody and I just wanted to bring you on
today and talk some [ __ ] this great
cat's catching up yeah yeah and just the
fact that we've been in this game almost
20 years together you just maybe will MA
I gave me the coke in the [ __ ] Austin
strip club what was the name of that
strip club Stanhope's friend
we always Lucky Strike no no though
though though we Mary is something she
does it would pick us up at the [ __ ]
yeah in like a like a limo bus limo bus
the strip club we'll just pick you yeah
and just take us right there and then
you gave me a package and I was in the
bathroom and oh the guys like the
bathroom it is like hey you can't be
doing that in here but stuff like that I
left is this water road and call them
did you give Fred one time in Vegas when
you got that eight ball and stuff no you
were just talking about you gave me a
little package and I put it in my front
of my jacket
got about it and I flew back home with
it and like years later I wore that Jack
and I was like what it was like oh this
is great what's still here yep that's
all that matters you got any dates
coming up with you know everything is
that deaf squad TV this Friday no leaves
gonna be there at the ice house in stage
2 8:30 show if you want to just swing by
to [ __ ] a nice house Chronicles yeah I
do ice house Chronicle still yeah yeah
well I'm gonna be where the [ __ ] am I
gonna be I'm gonna be in the Pittsburgh
improv guys the show's three of the
shows are sold out already
the other two are almost close I think
think I had a late show Thursday there
you have it and then for 19 I'm at the
Fitzgerald theater in Minneapolis and
for 20 I'm at the [ __ ] taps Peter is
that smoking dope in Milwaukee with the
spirit of [ __ ] raining
Jeffrey Dahmer me and Jeff we done
bringing Jeffrey Dahmer back from the
dead anyway thank you guys for this I
want thank read man I want to thank that
[ __ ] I want to thank you guys
for supporting this sorry about the
podcast this week we all had to heal
some way this is the best way to do it
we'll be back Monday morning tip-top
[ __ ] Magoo all right he's for a
word from our sponsors all right I want
to thank red man I want to thank the
flying Jew but most importantly I want
to thank you [ __ ] savages of death do
not forget Pittsburgh I think there was
40 tickets left and we might add an
extra show for the Late Show on Thursday
night that that's all gone Friday's gone
sadly is gone there's gonna be some
maximum fee on Thursday and then March 9
to April 19th 3 420 smile but listen I'm
pulling the Minneapolis Lynn on fire
with [ __ ] buds in my ear you
understand me I'm over at something
beautiful Fitzgerald theater downtown
Minneapolis and then for 20 the Pabst
Theater and [ __ ] mill walking me and
Jeffrey Dahmer sparking [ __ ] numbers
eating [ __ ] toes you don't say well
who gives a [ __ ] this belong to anyway
real quick I wanted to do shoe to a new
company I love I they sent me a bye
and I tried out their stuff and it was
so good I reached out to that this is
the [ __ ] I reached out to them I
started with the gummies
they had these gummies they don't get
you high nothing like that but I
couldn't believe how good I was feeling
in the morning you know there's a lot of
see me these companies out there you
don't know what to do you don't know
where to start
thank God thank God that I get these
[ __ ] little treats and I get to try
them out myself and I get to tell you
about the results but CBD Lyon is the
way to go
they make CBD products from start to
finish
CBD Lyon has you covered all right when
you go to CBD Lyon calm and check out
their third party lab results yourself
you're gonna [ __ ] flip listen whether
you like to vape it if you like the vape
they got cartridges in Chadha if you're
not into smoking it then forget about it
either gummy bear or do what I do go
with the Texas I put it under my tongue
30 seconds ban when I wake up in the
morning guys I'm telling you the truth I
even make a [ __ ] video of me taking
it when I wake up in the morning the
last month last six weeks I've been
waking up a little pep in my step even
this morning I didn't sleep through the
last night but I wasn't [ __ ] sore now
what did you do cheer saying I told you
so
do me a favor call the CBB line.com
right now if this read everything they
got terpene potential health benefits
charts they got so little so much
information on their webpage from
disposable car to distinctions
disposable vapes CBD lotion CBD isolates
listen
so anything CBD go to CBD line calm
right now you on the way out in the box
you press Church CH you are CH and
you're gonna go Joey where the [ __ ] did
you find these [ __ ] savages CBD Lyon
calm let me ask you something
you ready to start a new business you
really wanted to stand that will get it
started with Squarespace alright because
you think it your dream it and then you
make it happen
with Squarespace destiny is calling it
says you need a new website make it with
Squarespace
the future is coming make it brighter
with Squarespace
stop dreaming make it a reality with a
website
from Squarespace listen you can create a
beautiful website turn your cool idea
sell products and services promote your
physical and online business and
announce upcoming events or special
projects ok that's what you got there so
if I was you I'd head over to
squarespace.com right now because
they're offering the church family a
free trial when you're ready to launch
use offer code Church and save 10% off
your first purchase of a website or a
domain
listen Square space does it by giving
you beautiful templates created by
world-class designers the ability to
customize the look and the feel the
settings the products and more with just
a few clicks
everything is optimized for mobile right
out of the box it's a new way to buy
domains and choose from 200 extensions
analytics that help you grow in real
time a built in search engine so for
optimization
free and secure hosting and nothing to
patch or upgrade ever and 24/7
award-winning customer support that's
what I want when I put up together a
website so do me a favor head over to
squarespace.com right now for a free
trial when you're ready to launch use
off the code Church CH you are CH and
I'm gonna give you a 10% off for right
from your website or your domain that
squarespace.com enter code Church I want
to thank Squarespace
I want to thank CBD Lyon calm but most
importantly I want to thank you guys for
being [ __ ] savages and for having our
backs I'll see you guys Monday morning
ready to go tip-top of goo okay have a
great weekend don't forget about me and
I'll see you [ __ ] next week
throw me kiss Lea there you go stay
black tux up is uncle Joey loves you see
you next week